when the American war for independence
broke out thirteen of Britain's North
American colonies opted to sever ties
with the mother country however some of
those colonies chose to remain loyal and
afterwards would go on to form the
Dominion of Canada thus the question is
why didn't Canada join the American
Revolution before continuing it's
important to stress that in 1775 Canada
didn't exist it was instead comprised of
the colonies of Newfoundland Nova Scotia
Quebec Rupert's land and Saint John's
Island bar in Quebec the differences
between the peoples of these states and
those of the thirteen colonies were no
more or less stark before it can be
determined why all of the colonies
didn't leave it's necessary to know why
the thirteen that did leave chose to
break away in the first place much of
the anger directed at Britain was due to
the idea that the recent acts of King
George the 3rd and his Parliament
violated the rights of Englishmen this
is why the province of Quebec had no
interest in revolting since you know it
wasn't English speaking of Quebec it was
itself one of the reasons for the
revolution the Quebec Act had expanded
the size of the french-speaking colony
and granted freedom of religion there
which did the Protestant
english-speaking colony surrounding them
was terrible
for Quebec it's options were to stay
with Britain whom they didn't exactly
like but who granted them rights and
more territory or to the rebels who
despised them but what about when the
French began to help the Americans
didn't Quebec want to go back to being
under French rule well no being a
British colony gave Quebec access to a
much larger international trading market
and also to put it bluntly the French
didn't really care about it anymore
another reason for the American
rebellion is what are known as the
Intolerable Acts things like the Stamp
Act the Sugar Act and the quartering act
took away rights and privileges that
American colonists had previously held
which shockingly upset them the taxes
that Britain imposed were done so
without the consent of the Americans
leading to cries of no taxation without
representation to which Britain's
response was to people living in Britain
itself barely have representation so
what makes you so special
also mass financial problems across the
colonies combined with the ban on
expanding westward in order to prevent
war with the Indians meant the
revolution wasn't too far away some of
these acts combined with economic issues
negatively affected the peoples of the
later Canadian colonies just as badly
unlike the 13 colonies though the
reaction wasn't quite as fierce there in
places like Rupert's land and Saint
John's Island the acts weren't quite as
important since their economies relied
on natural resource extraction
whereas in Newfoundland and Nova Scotia
the acts were just as disruptive these
colonies did see some resistance
two British policies Nova Scotia had
close ties to New England that much of
its population were immigrants from
there
thus they too were angry at the new
taxes and this anger culminated in a
couple of riots but ultimately no more
than that much of this was down to the
province being much less urbanized and
so what little resistance there was
couldn't be organized quickly Nova
Scotia's economy was also reliant on the
British military since Halifax was a
garrison town which played host to many
Royal Navy vessels another factor which
secured their allegiance was the British
troops were needed to fight off Indian
raiding speaking of which raiding by
American privateers during the war
drastically soured the relationship
between Nova Scotia and the thirteen
rebelling colonies had guaranteed
further the Nova Scotia would remain
loyal to Britain as for Newfoundland
many of its residents were fishermen who
would either relocated from Britain
recently over there for a season to work
and thus inclusion in the British Empire
was necessary for their livelihoods
whilst Newfoundland had many problems
similar to those in the American
colonies its distance meant that it
lacked a sense of solidarity with those
to its south
thus they saw themselves not as
colonists but as being entirely British
and most their believes that their
problems would not be solved by
political separation there were two
other important reasons for Nova Scotia
and Newfoundland remaining loyal the
first was that the elites of the
colonies hadn't lost any money from
Britain's actions like those in save the
junior of Massachusetts
they were mostly naval officers whose
income came from their own lands back in
Britain and whose position relied on
loyalty reason number two was a simple
one proximity it was quicker to sail to
Newfoundland and Nova Scotia than any of
the American colonies meaning that any
retaliation that did happen would have
hit them first and that was not a
tantalizing proposition for them I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching with extra thanks to my
patrons that you see on screen now and a
special thanks to James Bissonnette
izalco flash mark H party-boy Co David
archaeologist Rob Waterhouse Chris
wicker Michael Reynolds Gustav Swan
onion Duck David Silverman Paul Maggie
packs Kowski Winston K wood vasily era
vedas christian check hey Anthony
Beckett Skye Chappell Adam Harvey and
Ike